[Música]
Estados Unidos no descarta declarar a
los carteles mexicanos de la droga como
grupos terroristas así lo aseguró el
secretario de estado Anthony blinquen la
medida se enmarcaría en la política de
Washington para luchar contra el ingreso
de drogas a suelo estadounidense
la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos Da inicio a las audiencias por
el caso de Beatriz versus El Salvador el
suceso se ha remonta a 2013 cuando las
estrictas leyes antiaborto del país la
obligaron a seguir con su embarazo Pese
a que estaba en riesgo su vida y el feto
sufría de malformaciones
la situación humanitaria en Colombia
sigue deteriorándose según informó el
comité Internacional de la Cruz Roja la
organización advierte que la situación
se da en medio del fortalecimiento de
grupos armados y la lucha territorial
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Norteamérica las relaciones entre
Estados Unidos y México siguen sumando
tensiones el secretario de estado
estadounidense Anthony blinken aseguró
frente a un comité del senado que el
gobierno podría considerar a los
cárteles mexicanos como organizaciones
terroristas unas declaraciones que
llegan Poco después de que el presidente
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador
tildara de mentirosas a las autoridades
estadounidenses por un reporte sobre
violaciones a los derechos humanos en el
país
la lucha contra el narcotráfico pone
tambalear las relaciones entre Estados
Unidos y México en una sesión del comité
del senado estadounidense el secretario
de estado Anthony blinquen aseguró que
parte del territorio mexicano está
controlado Por los carteles de la droga
y que las acciones para contrarrestar su
tráfico deben ser mayores un objetivo
para el que no descartó catalogará las
bandas mexicanas como terroristas qué
tal esta idea en vez de solo intervenir
en la frontera vamos a la raíz y
declaramos a los carteles como
organizaciones terroristas bajo la ley
estadounidense lo consideraría sí
ciertamente lo consideraríamos una
afirmación que matizó al anotar que
México ha incautado cantidades récords
de fentanilo y sentenció que ambos
países están colaborando muy de cerca
las declaraciones sin embargo no fueron
bien tomadas por varios sectores de la
sociedad mexicana por lo que el
canciller del país intentó calmar los
ánimos Marcelo ebrard dijo que blinquen
se encontraba en una encrucijada y dada
por el senador republicano Lindsay
graham quien cuestionó al secretario de
estado durante la audiencia una actitud
mediadora que contrasta con la del
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador quien elevó el tono al criticar
las acusaciones de violaciones de
derechos humanos de Estados Unidos a su
país se creen el gobierno del mundo
se asumen
como el gobierno del mundo
nada más decir que no es cierto que son
unos mentirosos según el gobierno
mexicano del país incautado más de seis
toneladas de fentanilo en los últimos
meses en operativos que han causado la
muerte de 75 agentes de sus fuerzas de
seguridad
el presidente de la reserva Federal de
Estados Unidos
anunció una subida de la tasa de interés
en un cuarto de Punto y dijo que la
institución sigue comprometida con
llegar a la meta de reducir la inflación
al 2% refiriéndose a la quiebra de los
bancos silicon Valley y signature
aseguró que los depósitos de los
ahorradores estadounidenses están
seguros y que el sistema bancario es
sano
la reserva Federal en colaboración con
el departamento del tesoro y la FBI c
tomó medidas decisivas para proteger la
economía de los Estados Unidos y
fortalecer la confianza pública a
nuestro sistema bancario estas acciones
demuestran que todos los ahorros de los
depositantes en el sistema bancario
están seguros en Nueva York se celebra
la conferencia del agua de la ONU es la
primera vez en casi medio siglo que se
celebró un evento de este tipo justo
cuando aumentan los llamados a proteger
este Preciado líquido en medio de los
intentos o de los impactos generados por
la crisis climática previamente María
Clara calle nuestra enviada especial a
la gran manzana nos contaba Cuáles
fueron las propuestas de los líderes
mundiales durante la primera jornada del
encuentro
la propuesta más sonada es que se cree
un enviado especial de la ONU para el
agua que es una idea que está liderando
desde el año pasado Alemania por ejemplo
la ministra de medio ambiente alemana
stefy lem que considera que esta figura
ayudaría a tratar todos los temas del
agua de manera transversal dentro de
Naciones Unidas Y hasta ahora 150 países
han respaldado la idea sin embargo
todavía no es una realidad la segunda
propuesta más escuchada es que más
países se adhieran al convenio del agua
de la ONU que es la que obliga
legalmente a los países miembros a que
pacten acuerdos para proteger las aguas
que cruzan fronteras y a que no tengan
conflictos entre sí El problema es que
esto inicialmente aplicaba Solo para
Europa y desde 2006 se abrió para el
resto de los países de la ONU desde
Entonces únicamente diez naciones han
firmado este convenio el último día en
hacerlo fue este miércoles Nigeria y
otro compromiso tiene que ver con dinero
Estados Unidos prometió 49 mil millones
de dólares para priorizar la resiliencia
en temas de agua y saneamiento pero más
allá del dinero la mayoría de los países
se han concentrado en hablar de lo que
han hecho y no de lo que van a hacer lo
cual no va con el llamado de la ONU en
poner el pie en el acelerador
este miércoles iniciaron las audiencias
en la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos por el caso de Beatriz versus El
Salvador la historia de una joven
salvadoreña enferma de lupus a la que en
2013 se le impidió interrumpir su
embarazo pese a las afecciones para ella
y para el feto que iba a nacer con una
malformación congénita las estrictas
leyes antiaborto en la nación
centroamericana obligan a las mujeres
gestantes a seguir adelante con sus
embarazos si no pueden asumir condenas
de hasta 50 años de prisión ahora la
corte tiene en su poder obligar al
Estado salvadoreño a cambiar esta Norma
Aunque la decisión nos espera antes de
finales de año durante la primera
jornada de audiencias la madre de la
joven pidió que este tipo de casos no se
repitan
este caso que le pasó a Beatriz no le
vuelva a pasar a ninguna otra mujer
pasamos a Colombia el comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja lanzó una
alerta sobre el deterioro de la
situación humanitaria del país según el
cicr por quinto año consecutivo la
situación ha empeorado debido al aumento
en las cifras de desplazamiento forzado
y el recrudecimiento del conflicto con
diferentes grupos al margen de la ley
previamente hablamos con Lorenzo caraji
jefe de la delegación del comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja en
Colombia quien nos explicó Cuáles son
los factores que han llevado a la Cruz
Roja a lanzar esta alerta
Buenas noches Andrés Buenas noches al
televidentes de France El Seis se
representa afortunadamente cada año aquí
en Colombia estamos en las condiciones
de presentar cada año un informe que
reporta los datos sobre consecuencias
humanitarias actividades recomendaciones
del año anterior en este caso Entonces
los datos que reportamos son datos de
2022 y efectivamente las estadísticas
datos nuestros y de las autoridades
colombianas muestran que el deterioro de
la situación como usted lo dijo continuó
como existe desde 2018 en 2022 eso
manifiesta con datos como Víctimas de
desplazamiento masivo que fueron 58.000
en 2022 un aumento de casi el 10%
Comparado 2021
desplazamiento individual 123.000
personas se desplazaron se declararon
desplazadas individualmente al primero
de diciembre 2022 en el mismo periodo
2021 había sido 77.000 o sea con un
aumento del más de 60%. por lo mismo de
la misma manera registramos a 500 15
víctimas
de artefactos explosivos o sea Minas
antipersonales restos exclusivos de
guerra artefactos lanzados y detonación
controlada es el número más alto de los
últimos seis años
en Bolivia las protestas de los maestros
entraron en su tercera semana cientos de
personas salieron nuevamente a las
calles de la Paz para exigir Un aumento
en el presupuesto del sector educativo
las movilizaciones derivaron en
enfrentamientos con la policía que
disparó pertigones y gases lacrimógenos
para dispersar a los manifestantes que
también lanzaron explosivos y otros
objetos para este viernes los docentes
convocaron un paro y advirtieron con
bloquear carreteras si el gobierno del
presidente Luis Arce no accede a sus
demandas nosotros estamos pidiendo un
presiento porque el gobierno solamente
da nos da el 10%
el como el el diálogo fue roto el día de
ayer entonces por eso estamos se ha
masificado las las los enfrentamientos
con la policía y lo único que nosotros
queremos es mejorar pues la calidad
educativa
hasta aquí es informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]